à l'occasion du tournoi on a été les
seuls à avoir une inteview exclusive de
novak djokovic ans est le numéro un
mondial
voilà le serbe il nous a fait des
confessions sur ses rivaux sur sa vie de
famille sur sa fondant sur sa fondation
et on a même fait un petit ping pong
ensemble regardez comme c'est beau quand
tu fais moi aussi je me suis mis sion
peut-être je mange plus tard chez moi il
ya du bruit non là dans les boulets qui
a dû franchement j'ai beaucoup de boue
est on voulait il ya beaucoup de il ya
du gluten sont obligés on ne peut pas
arrêter d'en bas qui a dit que j'étais
différente sur les contres appel ou pas
je me suis je dit il me reste dans cinq
ans je te bats secours dans l'avant dans
les confrontations entre toi et nadal
est touriste et derrière c'est toi qui
est devant tu penses tu as un ascendant
psychologique sur ou pas oui oui un peu
vraiment un point avant mais donnant
dans le jeu pas mais doivent justement
concentrer sur le prochain point
mais avant de partir oui tout le monde
se dit on a plus à voir djokovic nadal
et federer on va faire quoi et comment
on fait comment n'ont qu'à contacter
encore du temps doux et toi tu vas jouer
jusqu'à 40 ans et 5 ans j'ai
l'impression que l'après tennis ça fait
pas peur
t'as pas t'as pas peur d'arrêter non non
non vraiment non je suis content comment
je suis motivé encore je suis inspiré de
g77 cette belle sport et j'ai pas
vraiment à l'obligation de jouer ne
donne pas de voile à deux buts de niort
parce que j'ai j'ai vraiment pas j'ai pu
parler cette obligation je peux arrêter
demain je suis aussi le papa de deux
enfants donc
monfils 5 ans et ai commencé avec
l'école et toute chose donc je voudrais
être avec lui avec mon petit fille n'ont
jamais vraiment une vaste et de tant de
femmes il y aussi un des plus gros
joueurs du monde et en plus il
yal'association aussi pour les enfants
oui oui fondation qui est déjà là pour
dix ans il me semble qu'on se fait en
prise kuljic et éducation en rêvant de
l'école c'est génial ça c'est un truc
c'est important pour toi c'est important
parce qu'ils aient enfin j'étais assez
le bi l'expérience de guerre en espérant
que tous les choses et j'ai développé à
ne pas dire mon carrière de cette
place-là jeu via j'avais plus belle
place du monde mais après je tennis mais
je sais aussi nous aimons a commandé
début nous des mobiles ethniques
oui c'est le sourire cette manière
ils ont tien an men a rencontré
fonctions jusqu'au bout de le voir à la
fois que vous êtes sportif douce
bassement on avait déjà vu d'avoir des
yeux comme ça parce que franchement
c'est comment on fait était humain
j'adore et c'est un mec exceptionnel
c'est un amour il perd sympa c'est un à
moi